given the current situation of the
united states
one of the largest questions on a lot of
people's minds is how is the rest of the
world doing during this time
recently we were able to collect some
comms called the langley report
based on the name and the nature of
these reports we now have confirmation
that the cia is still active globally
at least in some sort of capacity but
what information is contained in this
report
and is the rest of the world fearing as
badly as the united states during this
[Music]
[Music]
time
status update sync with mexican
ambassador arturo lechuga
major urban areas are decimated and
rural areas and the baja peninsula
are fine well [ __ ] zara i guess we
should take a vacation to camo
not funny sir lighten up
the world's [ __ ] whether we like it or
not
it should come as no surprise that the
united states neighboring country of
mexico
has been hit pretty hard by the outbreak
major cities have broken down
but rural areas including the land mass
to the left of the gulf of california
have remained unaffected though the
fleeing of residents from urban centres
may change this over time however it's
the border to the south that could
present larger concerns for mexico over
the coming months
[Music]
central and south america have fared
relatively poorly
the breakdown in government services has
factionized the survivors
and they've coalesced into warlord
factions often led by former cartels
with strong regional paramilitary power
cartels [ __ ] not solely sir
but certainly without markets for their
products cartels have consolidated
control over regions
we have reports of violent clashes with
existing governmental militaries as well
well that's just [ __ ] perfect if
comparing the state of central
and south america to the united states
these countries seem to be in a much
worse position
while the u.s has had an uprising of
hostile factions the cartels have been
active in south america
for over 60 years with the collapse of
the local governments
very little has been able to stop them
from carving out new territory
although the market for their general
distribution of drugs has become
difficult for them to accommodate
they are now fighting over and
controlling whole regions and the
remaining populations
as well as the minimal supplies that are
available
what little is left of government forces
are under-supplied
and spread too thin to provide any sort
of resistance to the cartel expansion
the main concern for mexico and the us
is where they will turn to next
when the food and medicine dries up
status update sync with canadian
intelligence
major urban areas are decimated and
canada's national emergency strategic
stockpile has been activated
most of the western half of the country
has dodged the worst of it rural bc
is mostly unscathed i'm sensing a theme
here zara
live out in bfe you're probably fine
yes sir that seems to be correct
no son of a [ __ ] preppers ain't gonna
let anyone live this down
that's the least of our concerns sir
to the north much like mexico populated
areas have been hurt
hard being the closest country to the
point of where the outbreak first struck
canada had little time to react however
the western side of the country seems to
be faring a little better where
stockades have been put in place
to stop the free movement of outsiders
from infecting these communities
[Music]
status update official report from the
eu despite political paralysis around
committing people to quarantine many
european countries
have weathered the outbreak well
healthcare systems manage treatments and
they've shown a high rate of success in
treating the symptoms
sounds like a load of socialist [ __ ]
the numbers don't lie sir
that said the collapse of their trading
partners has significantly impacted
urban centers with service economies
europe has feared a little better than
most western eu countries have done well
with isolating themselves from the worst
of the outbreak
and have managed to keep their
healthcare systems intact allowing them
the opportunity to adequately quarantine
and treat the sick however although they
are performing better with the outbreak
of the virus
their problems are only just beginning
the breakdown of the global economy
is quickly catching up with them more
than 50
of food alone is required to be imported
in order to feed the population
europe faces some difficult times in the
months ahead
status update as expected not much in
the way of information
global economic trade collapse seems
like it has an outsized impact on the
middle east
opec countries are actively looking to
trade crude stockpiles for critical
medicine and supplies
that's a damn good thing we restarted
drilling in anwar
would have been even worse if we had to
trade for oil sir anwar drilling
operations have been completely hotted
since the outbreak
why the hell would they stop i believe
they experience difficulty drilling
without sufficient staff
unsurprisingly information on this
region is shaky
but regardless of impact from the virus
they seem to be in a position of power
although they are feeling the effects of
the current global trade situation
the organization of petroleum exporting
countries have vast stockpiles of crude
oil
of which all countries are running
desperately low at this stage
so they'll be finding themselves in a
good position to control the trade
market going forward
status update sync with agent station
outside moscow
despite a major effort to contain the
spread criminal enterprises toward
the quarantine just enough to ensure the
containment failed
i hope that bare-chested buffoon
suffered
i'm not sure that's pertinent sir i
don't give a
[ __ ] he's a menace to stability and
peace
russia has failed to contain the virus
they've essentially found themselves in
a similar position to what the united
states is in
rising hostile factions have put a stop
to what little procedures the government
were able to put in place
including quarantines and other
containment facilities
it's unclear how the government is doing
but signs are pointing to them having
hunkered down
to weather out the storm given russia's
vast geographical diversity
it's unlikely that all regions of russia
have been hit
secluded communities are in a good
position right now as a large number
have had to live self-sufficiently
and independent of the larger russian
community for decades now
it's possible that the government has
relocated to one of these sites
while they figure out what to do next
status update reports out of asia have
been mixed
economic devastation and catastrophic
loss of life have been reported across
the continent
but many regions seem to be largely
untouched as well
chinese authorities claim the situation
is under control but satellite imagery
shows heavy population migration out of
urban areas
mix how what are we talking about
initial news at of larger metropolitan
areas show devastating viral spread but
somation countries have had little issue
in rapid quarantine procedures
so you're saying that human rights
abuses have their benefits
not at all sir i'm simply stating the
reality that some countries have had
less political backlash with strict
lockdowns
again it isn't surprising that the
information coming out of the countries
in asia
or more specifically china are sending
mixed messages
the integrity of the publicly provided
information has been questionable for
decades
larger centres have been hit hard but
because of the isolated nature of a
number of countries in the communities
within them
the further spread of the virus seems to
have been halted
quarantines have been put in place and
the government as a whole seems
completely intact
a number of these countries should see
no problems in making it through this
situation
given that they have now survived the
worst of the outbreak
status update report from our ambassador
to india
widespread outbreak and nearly complete
social and economic collapse following
in its wake
major population centers have been
devastated by the virus
india why the [ __ ] am i going to be
worried about india right now
have you seen the state of this place in
nuclear weapons
sir what about them india has them
if the government collapses and can
protect their stockpile that's an issue
for us and
really everyone
india's largely overpopulated landmass
is the perfect breeding ground
for a large scale and deadly pandemic
such as the dollar flu
given its highly contagious nature even
the best reaction to this virus would
have seen them struggle to contain the
spread
the entire country seems to have been
decimated
and although this is disheartening to
see there are larger concerns around
this
recent estimates suggest that india has
around 150 to 200 nuclear warheads
and has enough weapons-grade plutonium
that could be used for further
production of nuclear weapons
given their geographical location and
the fact that the middle east is the
only region
with an excess of oil there is a high
risk of neighboring extremist groups
willing to take advantage of the current
global crisis
and commandeer the nuclear arsenal to
further their own agenda
status update such a low population
density and already
spotty government support structures
across many african nations
much seems to remain largely unchanged i
don't give a [ __ ]
about africa why are you even briefing
me about it
it's my job sir well stop briefing me on
a continent with virtually no
geopolitical significance
what the [ __ ] would we even do about
africa care
sir you know i still have family there
sir although major centres are likely to
have been hit
especially to the south and north of the
country the majority of africa's
population has remained untouched during
this time
decades of isolation and minimal contact
from the outside world
have left the bulk of african countries
in one of the best positions
that one could hope to be in during this
time even the global economic collapse
should have a little impact on the
majority of these communities
status update immediate quarantines set
in place and major points of ingress to
japan were quickly shut down
while this prevented the spread of the
virus food and supply shortages have
been causing havoc
fishing communities are pitching in to
fill the shortfall must be nice to be an
island nation
i'm not sure starvation is better than
the virus sir
i am this is a plague of biblical
proportions
it's not a plague sir stop being so
goddamn pedantic
japan faced this virus with a clinical
precision that was able to quickly and
efficiently shut down any traces of the
dollar flu from taking hold of the
general population
however much like the situation in
western europe japan typically imports
60 of the food required to feed its
large population
and with the global trade having been
completely shut down extra pressure is
being placed on the fishing communities
to fill this gap
although japan has effectively
quarantined the whole country from the
virus
their problems are only about to start
as they quickly run through the
remaining vital supplies
with no clear answer for the future
so other than the fact that this
brigadier general green is a complete
asshat
what else will be able to learn of
what's happening across the globe
it's highlighted that although there are
some countries that are in a worse
position than the us
there are still a number of countries
that are in a better more sustainable
situation
however even these countries are facing
some difficult times ahead
the more advanced highly populated areas
will be feeling the after effect of the
collapse of the global trade and economy
where starvation sanitation and medical
supplies
will quickly become an issue i had
initially gone into quite a bit of depth
with each of these countries
digging right into the likely outcome
based on the unique geographical
political and societal situation each of
these regions faces
but unfortunately it was getting just a
little bit too
real especially based on what's
currently happening in the world
and i didn't want to appear as being
insensitive to what a lot of you are
facing these days
so although the map i put together will
still show some of this i've tried to
turn it down a little bit
being based in new zealand it could be
easy to forget about the fact that there
is a global pandemic going on speaking
of which
these comms really didn't cover new
zealand or australia
i'm sure we were meant to come home to
asia but let me update that map for you
relatively isolated from the rest of the
world australia and new zealand have
done pretty well in closing off borders
and setting up quarantine for those who
have had the potential to have been
infected
given the low population density of each
of these nations
self-sustainability of basic
requirements like food won't be a
problem in the long run
while i'm at it new zealand has a long
history of innovation to help them get
through the hard times
and regardless of what you hear the
aussies say they were the origins of
such things
as the pavlova the lamington pharlap
and russell crowe though to be fair
they can have russell crowe we don't
want him
anyway i hope you've enjoyed this video
and i'll catch in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
uh